they are images of grief from a small
island nation that has endured Civil War
flicked but which has never had visited
upon it an atrocity quite like this and
not only grief but anger - why us why
this why now many died as they prayed in
Catholic churches killed quite possibly
for their religion and this is the story
of just two Sri Lankan families torn
apart by terror Sudesh : stands by the
bodies of his wife and young daughter
they were attending Easter Sunday
service at Saint Sebastian church he
left for some air
five minutes before the blast he heard
about the huge toys and I jump into the
chair and I saw that my daughter likes
on the floor
I don't know what to do and I was just
so my thought on the floor and I try to
lift the solid exactly the same next
step this story and another family young
mum and dad two small children also
killed at church also while they prayed
and gave thanks the grandmother refuses
to leave the side of the coffins the
children's uncle utterly distraught it
feels like we're all dead he says it
seems like a part of my body is cut just
two stories of two families among
countless others
an Easter Massacre that has caused such
suffering here and whose impact is being
felt right across a country that had
hoped for lonely that its troubles were
in the past